thank you
[Music]
have any of your guys's uh wives or
girlfriends ever told you that you ain't
[__] yes yes all the time
mayonnaise yeah my hands I would raise
all three yep
and that's why I met a kid I'm going
shopping yeah I'm buying all the pillows
yeah oh yeah
all right I get told that every day you
ever get told that when you have the flu
oh of course because they know [__]
guys are weak as hell when it comes to
being seriously what are what are our
wife say to us
two sides
what is it yeah yeah it's right it's um
it's the thing where like it it was
widely believed that when men get the
flu it's worse than when women get it I
don't think so bro really I don't think
so but it was highly believe that it was
actual scientific studies but how do you
like symptoms that the symptoms were
worse for men he was just turning to
[__] I know for sure like when I get
sick I'm like oh my God
she's like her responsibility like if I
need to cook or do whatever like she
just she's just [__] dripping all
over yeah I chew at you but then I'm
literally like oh my [__] god
to be honest I'm the exact same way too
yeah really so is it a do thing that's
the thing it's about to tell us that's
[__] and we're really just [__]
no it's not exactly [__] but it's
almost [__] so we're almost [__]
one second let me ask my wife
yeah don't tell what the article is just
ask her just ask her she's gonna yell
and see you right now oh bring your wife
to work dad Hey Mickey
we need a we need a life expert to tell
us the truth
tell us we have a question when when
we're both sick
who takes it more like a [__] you or me
me really really when we're both sick if
we're both sick if we have the flu or
something oh if we're both sick yeah
yeah oh yeah I am for sure yeah yeah if
if I'm sick though he treats me like a
freaking princess he'll like bring me
food
like anything
but also I've offered in the past and
he's like no no I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine he doesn't like me to take
care of him very much he's a man yeah
like when he had covered I made him
meals every day because he wasn't
allowed to access the kitchen but um
yeah I think we're more both sick like
we when we had covid but we didn't know
it was covered like it was the like
before Covenant became like was official
before but you know what all of us got
sick of that party like the Christmas
party yeah you were like everyone in JK
got sick we all thought we were dying
but he didn't he it was like late for
him so I got it first and I was [__]
dying and my throat was like burning and
I had like a crazy fever for a week and
um and then like it still hadn't gone
away but we went to Christmas and he
just started getting it and he like
wouldn't move and he was like we gotta
go back home like [__] I'm dying too
but I'm pulling through and he was like
I can't go
she's like you gotta come he's like I
can't even go to the car I'm like I have
the same temperature as you all right
there's a lot of details about me being
a [__]
I'm liking this part of the story no but
there's an interesting development with
that so there were actual scientific
studies that they really did think that
men's symptoms for the flu were worse in
women's but in Austrian University
conducted a study that now shows and
it's published in the journal to
override the old study that it's not
that men's symptoms are worse it's that
women's are pain threshold yeah yeah
kind of women women have a sex hormone
that triggers their immune system to
work faster and sooner so they get
better quicker than men I also heard
that there's a we have like a higher
pain tolerance because of childbirth
like like it has to be like higher like
but then his is hired because of his
kidney stone now a lot of uh he leveled
up a lot of my tattoo artist friends say
that they say like dudes squeal way more
than chicks I squealand
yeah girls can just take it a lot of
girls can just take it yeah
baby about it like I actually hurt
myself I'm like so [__] tough let's
go to bed time
yeah Isn't that cool that it's actually
not completely [__] but it's more
like women and men symptoms are the same
see I [__] knew it they just don't
stay sick as long as you're saying is
not the same but they're just stronger
than us that's what you're saying their
sisters kick in Faster yeah when we have
loogies and [__] like guys this we
create more disgusting bacteria and [__]
like when we incubate
and we [__] Hawk these big ass bloody
ass luggies out and then girls be like
and then like it's a little one dude
when Nikki headed over the second time
she [__] was painting our house whoa
yeah she's like taking a ladder out and
painting the house and [__] and I'm like
can I help you and she's like no you get
all streaky I'm like [__] out yeah
so that kind of shovels it right when it
comes to like health and Community
guaranteed on the [__] no there's not
it's not even like [__] it's not a close
race at all yeah do you try to tough it
out or no no I try for sure I try to
tough it out but when I see her sick I'm
like are you even sick like it looks
like you're over it in like 30 seconds
yeah you're down to have sex when she's
sick
good question and in the regular way hey
you know what we mean it's not about
sickness it's always about post period
you know what I'm talking about you know
like right after
they get really horny that's awesome I
know and you know you just got to be
down you got to be ready because when
I'm sick when I'm sick I'm not down for
anything
if somebody be saved by someone for
anything no
I'm dying you're really not when you're
sick it's like I'm not really down for a
[__] it's like even have a connection
with my penis obviously but that helps
me sleep better though but then Jill's
down to have sex when she's sick I was
like I thought you were sick you [__]
[__] I hate how to get that [__]
yeah that's the worst when they get sick
they get slightly it's like I'm not down
with that right now that's disgusting
keep that to yourself six feet please
dude you ever been so sweaty because
like you're [__] or you have a fever
or some [__] or it's summertime or
something yeah no and you're like you're
like you're like on top of your chick or
whatever the [__] and like you see like
sweat beating down from your face on
their face and it's just like what are
we doing here you gotta get a towel yeah
you gotta towel her off after hey
honestly once in a blue moon that's kind
of hot though is it yeah when you get
like really really sweaty and like well
you are just down the idea if it's more
cinematic than it actually is don't you
feel more self-conscious though I do
when I sweat on somebody if you're
talking about like some Jack and Rose
hand on the window [__] thing that's
awesome blue moon you got to go so
passionate that it's like disgusting
[__] you watch Sweat Go from your
nose to there between their eyes I sweat
like a [__] yeah when it drops
off with a Long Point in your nose
mine's like flat this goes like this it
kills yeah no it's boner Crusher yeah
boner Crusher for both parties 96 I
don't work that hard oh really
I don't even get to that point does the
girl ever sweat Joe's a lazy boy yeah
neither be [__] the cold oh
exclusively it's too hot his hair down I
can't do it or you can swim
yeah if it's like hot
wow we are [__] profound here just
kidding news bring it to you the news
first I was younger I remember being way
sweatier and then now I'm like wait I
was I it doesn't I don't sweat as much
as I used to you're thinking about it
right now yeah the conditions like
they're not always ideal when you were
younger yeah maybe I couldn't afford AC
back then
it's harder when you're younger where
you can do it Hey Joe remember last
night when we're in Bart's truck and
you're talking um to the camera guy Joe
about how you don't you can't believe we
met this long you're so glad that the
fans are with us still it's because
commentary like that yep yeah because I
am because I'm hot you're hooked are you
hooked because they're just like it's
cold yeah we should put that at the
beginning of the video
when you [__]
when it's hot
welcome to JK news
holy [__] I'm in come on
when I was younger I was way sweatier
but I haven't had any of the beads on
the nose in a long time the AC in Vegas
is way better though way better probably
way more dry it's way better but also I
just haven't sweat like that in a long
time you're also just used to it what
about your Strokes per minute do you
think that's higher as an adult or when
you're way lower yeah
I don't even know if I could last
[__] past like two minutes really
I feel like I come less and I take
longer used to be way longer
Justin over here he's like I'm Like A
Champion Maverick now yeah back in the
day you tried to make it last longer on
purpose yeah yeah that's what it is
just like I wish I did it did you ever
jerk off way too much before [__]
where you're we're then during it you're
kind of like ah [__] I jerked it way too
much this is nothing this is like I feel
nothing well no it's like it's more like
it's like you're going for like 20
minutes you're like man this poor [__]
is like really yeah she's she's looking
at her watch over it she's looking at
the clock she's getting an old newspaper
out and [__] cracking it open chicken
last week
just let me know when you're done all
right yeah what's the optimal time for
love making at this age seven minutes
where we're at now seven minutes do you
even keep time it feels like can we get
one more opinion it feels like an
abstract yeah that's a good Alaska
ideal time I'm not sitting on this side
while he does it I'm sitting over there
no come on do we need you in the shot
we need
a we need a Nicky opinion I didn't say
[__]
honest opinion
foreign
for sexual intercourse at this current
the pounding 15 minutes
15 minutes of pounding I said seven
oh God 15 minutes wait Steve says
because I was looking at it like uh yeah
okay the beginning yeah from the
beginning to we're like okay we know
that's what we're gonna happen full
ritual the full ritual of 15 minutes 15.
okay well well the full full like okay
after I come then 15 minutes
damn it takes me 11 minutes to get her
clothes off it goes down the prize I
don't know how to do this you have a
system
it works really well there's an epilogue
what's your guy's system Steve has to
stick his dick out of his zipper first
check it out my zipper I leave my pants
off it's your wife peeking out over it
and then I tickle him she tickles me
really hard yeah well I got a lot of
pretty going baby
she sucks on my nipples and then she
finger [__] my mouth and then I come
and I go hooped up good boy who's a good
boy and he goes I'm a good boy and I go
who's a good boy and then we we go like
this with each other and then she you
see why I changed the table yeah
dude it's on my legs and she powders my
butt and she puts me in a diaper and
then she said all that in 15 minutes
that's the pre and then 15 minutes okay
then it's hurt that's how he gets that's
how he gets hard and then 15 minutes
apart pounding and then hard pounding
hardcore pounding she's pounding him
well I have my pacifier in and I'm
holding my rattle
ritual 15 minutes hard pounding and then
something happens at the end excuse me
we've been together for a long time you
gotta do crazy [__] find what works for
you
like we found our system and we're
pretty locked in Mommy
I want my mommy
and then you burp him after
oh my God you guys should see the feed
me dude that has nothing to do with sex
either she was feeding me okay he loves
being fed
[Music]
foreign